right guys come around please quickly
come around come around listen it'll be
setting up an opening for the first time
yeah a pop-up bakery everything we
produce today there's gonna be sold to
the public and I need to leave here with
a van full not of prisoners but of tarts
I'm serious I need to get this stuff out
of it we need a catchy name for the shop
take a pen I'm thinking bad boys bakery
what are the lads think you are my tarts
have at our tea party it's a [ __ ]
cake shop not and summers made by hate
MP Brixton inmate tarts yeah
Nick these I'll cut your [ __ ] hands
off bad boy bakers I love that idea or
bad boy bakery but this is no BS now we
are going out and we are facing the
British public and we aren't going to be
telling them everything you buy here has
been made by prisoners okay so the bad
boys bakery is born okay good let's go
guys
oops anything to do prison pickle bit
whoa where you know that's
understandable don't necessarily want to
be bad people but it's about changing
and biased doing this gives us that hope
that we believe we can get a job
we're human time ran or one so seven
years I've got [ __ ] conscience in our
heart now I can never change I got the
change we're gonna do oh [ __ ]
yeah it's quite technical we gotta cook
and learn at the same time but I'm gonna
sell so we can't afford any mistakes
because everything they make eternal
don't throw any face your way guys yeah
every time we throw pastry away or try
money in the bin to make sure we draw in
the customers
I want the prisoners themselves to drum
up some business so I need you to put a
phone call in tonight mum Monty tell him
to get down this is 22 year old Jerome
Samuels first time in an Adult jail but
he's been in and out of trouble all his
life how old when you first hit the
streets 12 have you been inside young
offenders yeah where thank you
way my last night well crime in it
I'm a young age in it and I was young in
it my dad died immigrant not dead I see
my candidates face down in it burns me
in it and obviously I just for you know
what [ __ ] this I give up ain't got night
introduce normal right my mom and that
one shot me units out you just give it a
look
you don't do it again night the stock so
when he was gonna do something like
right did have no look lemon curd for me
growing up with all that little bit
tastes delicious
so first up a classic with a twist
lemon curd treacle tart can't Arden has
to be x-rayed I'm going through to